welcome to the Thursday morning session
and it's great to have you in talking
about non-negative matrix factorization
okay so this is joy work with Ian Julie
and andreas testing both students from
Princeton University so let's begin to
consider our recent advances in machine
learning applications so we have seen
significant advances along this machine
learning applications such as diction
learning meeches completion or and
especially deep learning and think a lot
of new things happening along with these
advances we see a lot of non convex
problems example I all of those
applications listy here I mean in the in
their general form of just non convex
problem although this is like comics
relaxation a Yuri the problem is
formulated in a non convex way so these
problems in their general form I just
hard to solve but it seems that the
practical instances are not so bad so
basically people are getting used to
formulate a problem in a non convex way
and just solve them by some heuristic
and get good results so they don't
they're not scare by this non convexity
and especially often yell be you some
simple method to get some local
improvement by that I mean um the simple
method often has multiple iterations and
at each iteration we just look at the
information at the current solution and
try to get some local improvement so the
most commonly used one is so-called
gradient descent and it's variants such
as stochastic gradient descent so
suppose we have some objective function
and we want to minimize it then we can
just pay the gradient at the current
solution and move a little bit along the
negative direction of the gradient
this is the very basic algorithm but
works really well so it's the basis for
the four exam of the deep learning and
another approach is this so-called
alternating update method so usually the
problem has two blocks or variables that
you need to determine so you fix one of
them you update the other and then you
fix the other and update the first one
and repeat this procedure the advantage
is there are many problems if you fix
one of the variables updating the other
is quite easy so this is very popular in
practice for such kind of problem if
they have the structure I just mentioned
so what so this is a concrete example
mages factorization we are given a
mage's wine and we want to find two
matrices you really low rank and then we
won y equal to the product of a times X
so then after doing some initialization
we can just say fix a and update X
basically like Phi the best x the
fixture that are fit the current a and
then we fix eggs and then fire the best
a that we can get so it's kind of like
some best response dynamics so it turns
out that on this tool very simple method
or heuristic was a really well for y
family or problem including like those
are listed on the first line but there's
no generally there's no theoretical
guarantee so the interesting questions
are when and why such algorithms
actually work for the hard problems so
the goal here is first made some natural
and clean assumption about the practical
instances and let me show that this
simple methods can actually recover what
we want
excuse me right that's a question so I
say quotes oh yeah could you stop it
after like 10 minutes o.o he's a good
values solution because you compare it
to something oh yeah that's a good
question so basically if you have an
object function by works I mean you can
minimize I you can get a solution that
is close to the global optimum either in
object function or in the solution
because if you know the glory they
probably have their different that goes
in this box better um yeah that's a good
question so basically for some of the
problems you may you may be able to show
that are all the local Optima are just
global Optima yeah proving self-examine
I'm majors completion under some
assumption I in coherence and random
tell you is not here yeah so basically
are for some problems you can show them
another way to show that in words is
then you assume some so-called January
model and in which you actually have a
growl truth so you want that growl truth
you don't care about the update function
you care about a grouch route so what
you want to show is then this algorithm
given the data from that distribution
after why you actually get close to the
underlying crowd truth so yeah so so be
yeah
display simulation um I mean generally
modifica oh yeah on January model if you
want to empirically verify new uri you
simile because you you have the journey
model you can just generate data but our
hope is that the general model is
natural in the sense that it may be is
close to the actual data distribution
that we observe in practice so that is
the hope yeah okay so this work is about
analyzing alternating updating for
non-negative matrix factorization so
then what is non-negative matrix
factorization is just the factorization
problem under that the additional
assumption that the entries of the
factorized matrices should be
non-negative so in some cases are you
only require are the entries of X is
non-negative but for simplicity let's
just say we required both are
non-negative so this leads to non convex
problem it's a important theoretical
concept basically relates to non- rang
and like log-rank conjecture in
communication complexity but here we
care more about its application in
machine learning it has many
applications here the typical one I mean
is the topic modeling which is a mixture
model for analyzing data such as tanks
images or even networks and many other
time of algorithm so here in this
setting the why mages so let's say each
column of why mages corresponds to a
document and each row correspond to some
word so each column is basically the
word distribution in this particular
document for example I this talking
has like 40 full fraction being the word
ring it's just a synthetic in example
and this majors a is called the top
images each column is called a topic
basically just a distribution over the
words but it's meaningful in the sense
that it corresponds to some concept for
example like this topic weather has a
large probability on this word ray and
has more probability over some other not
so related words like soccer physics and
things like that so this is the top
images and this X matches is our each
column of it corresponds to a document
and it's just a mixing coefficients of
the topics in this particular document
they say this document has poi to
fraction of the topic weather and as
poor a fraction of the topic science so
y equals a times X basically means then
by mixing the distribution of the topics
you get the distribution of the words in
this document so you can imagine that by
analyzing by discovering the topics
among a large set of documents you can
get an overview of the themes of this
document so it's very useful and popular
in social science and also like
information reachable in many areas
okay another example comes from computer
vision so you're applying non-negative
matrix factorization on images say this
example is coming from yeah a nature
paper so you're given some images about
human faces you want to find out this
so-called pattern images so each small
square it's actually an image of the
same size as this original face image so
reassuring it because we need to have
space so then you want to fire a bunch
of pattern images and then buy a non
negative linear mixture of these pattern
images you can recover the face image so
by piecing them up you can get this
phase image so now you don't know this
panel image you don't know the weight
you are given this on a bunch of images
so each image is just a column in the
are in our beaches wine then you run
this are non-negative matrix
factorization using alternating update
rules then you can discover some
interesting patterns some of the images
arm let's say this um this my
corresponds to the mouth of on human
faces and some others may corresponds to
eyebrows and things like that so you can
get a power base representation of human
faces so this is another home example so
it also has many other applications so I
never analyzing networks and no like
information reach you when things like
that
but as similar to some other machine
learning problems usually we have a
large gap between the worst case bound
and what happens in practice so Aurora
girl cannon boy toy show that this is no
sub exponential algorithm assuming ETH
and also given our algorithm running
exponentially in k k is the number of
columns in the main chest eh so you can
see that this basically is impractical
in for for any practical use but what
happens in practice is just this
heuristic suggested by the computer
vision guys Lee and song that you can
just do alternating update after setting
a initialization so usually set by some
human experts on this our data set and
then you can just repeat the two steps
you compute X from a you compute a basin
eggs so I'll be more specific about
about this algorithm later on but but
this is just a simple algorithm you can
just run and get very good results so
this large gap just requires some
analysis for practical instance rather
than worst-case instance so how do you
model practical instance for machine
learning applications so the most common
way to do so is so-called generative
model where you assume there's a growl
truth solution so here let's say we have
a growl truth a star meeches and then
you assume that the data is generated
from a distribution defined based on
this crowd truth so it has some
information are about the groucho that
you want to discover the crowd truth
based on the data so another approach to
do up your own worst case analysis for
machine learning problems is so-called
warm star basically is assuming the
initialization
is not far away from this crowd truth
for example here is not far away from
the crowd shows this is motive a
motivated by the fact that the
initialization is often set by some
human experts so it's reasonable to
assume that is better than just random
guessing so you can assume that is not
too far away okay so what do we know
about nmf this paper proposed the
so-called separability assumption
motivated by topic modeling the
assumption says then each topic
basically each column of the matrix a
has an so co-anchor word or what is an
ankle word is just a word that appear in
this particular topic but not do not
appear in any other topics so under such
kind of assumption disease efficient
algorithm for this problem and and you
can just run in an actuary there's a lot
of subsequent world on this line and
there are a very practical algorithms
another related work is our by our see
every harvest esky they analyze this arm
variation inference method basically
it's a an alternating of the method for
topic modeling they ought only
alternating over a anx try to minimizing
the KL divergence between the columns of
y and the columns of a times X so in
this work basically it requires quite
strong assumption and a and also a warm
start depending on the diamond dynamic
range of the entries in the majors a so
which is not so are realistic so and
also are the assumptions may not hope
for some other time of data be long text
for some like computer vision the
assumption is a little bit of
so the interesting question is can we
show our provable guarantee of the
simple method under more general
assumption so now let's turn to our word
I would describe the model algorithm and
then provide the results and an overview
of the analysis so this is our
generative model you just assume that
each column or why basically a data
point is Heidi example from this
distribution hey start times X star here
a star is a deterministic groucho's
mages and X star is a random variable of
vector so then we can for simplicity
let's assume that we have infinite data
then the only assumption about the mages
a star is linear independence so this is
very my condition first of all is a
generalization of the angle word
condition and also on we kind of expect
the columns of a to be convex
independent otherwise is even
non-identifiable in a sense that you may
have flying infinite number of a they
satisfy the data so this is so although
there is a difference between linear
independence and comics independence but
we don't know how to make use of there
so you just assume linear independence
now we also assume some distribution on
the our random vector X star we assume
that the coordinates are independent so
this is the key assumption and we also
assume that is just 0 1 is one with
certain probability as well otherwise so
in expectation this is a vector with our
as nonzero entries being one and all the
others being 0 so just a very simple
model
so our analysis generalized to are some
other more general assumptions but this
is sufficient for demonstrating our
intuition escorting setting as well
because X is a sparse vector and a 0 our
results generalized to non spasm a
trousseau sparsity is not an another key
assumption here but the Impi
independence is the key assumption so
it's also called non-negative hi CA
independent component analysis in the
empirical papers but we don't find any
theoretical analysis for their service
to yeah yes I should think of as being
somewhat close to care or don't care
something well you can think of it as
dead it can be sparse and it can be non
spouse but it doesn't matter so so fast
was one this would be easy cake cakes
are k is the number of k's decide i had
the number of columns in a so if s was
one then you would be seeing some
columns of a and your wife right yeah
that would be the case
ok let's continue so this is our
algorithm you have some parameters that
I will explain later but basically is
just the alternate update in the first
step we compute X recorded decoding just
online communication literature
basically means there for each example
why you try to get the corresponding X
how do you get it you just multiply it
by the pseudo inverse of the current
solution that's why we need in linear
independence and then we pass it through
a nonlinear function one looks like this
and then get X so what is the nonlinear
function it applies to each coordinate
of the input vector and for each and
each coordinate if it smaller than alpha
then says it to zero otherwise just keep
the original value so this is called
rectified linear Union relew in deep
learning and it turns out is crucial for
proving the commercials resolve in our
setting so there might be some
connection to that but we do know loop
dependent on T and what if a could you
explain one more time oh ok so so here I
just omit the sub squared T so let's say
it because let's for simplicity we
assume that you have infinite data so
each time you just sample a lot a lot of
Y and then for each why you use the
current solution let's say this is 80
you use the pseudo inverse of the
current solution 80 and then you get the
decoding and then I've used this the
codings in updating 8280 plus 1 let's
say
rotation is factoring why you to eight
times x rays I tried but yeah well I
guess that algorithm start completely
there oh no you haven't told you how the
Jagger is also a tea the new Tiger was
the psychology book of Esther yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah so there should be
yeah there should be a superscript T or
sub square t inside this dagger that
yeah so
okay after getting the decoding we just
do the update is also quite simple we
just compute some direction and I move
along that direction so what would the
direction is just the expectation / y
minus y prime times X minus X prime
transpose so this is a vector this is a
row vector so you get a you get a
matches out of this so here y and y
prime are two independent examples and
XNX prior their risk corresponding to
codys so we need to use some a
polynomial number of example but here i
just take expectation for simplicity
questions like why I had nothing to do
with the wire I mean this why so you can
think of it as I let's say m copies and
M examples y 1 up to ym right so we just
use the first half as as this the second
heir how has this see wait that's
confusing we're just depending example
right what's the half um ok so we let's
say we draw two sets of examples oh yeah
so the first day of example we are
decoded in this way the second set we
also do in this way and then we use the
first set as why the second sent has y
prime and then we can use free samples
for analysis year because they simplify
things alone but it's just logarithmic
iteration so it's ok with and some extra
were you you may be able to show that
you don't need independent sample but it
just complicate things
the matrix completion setting which is
kind of similar it's really it was
difficult to get rid of this oh so here
is slightly different it's not so
difficult to get rid of the fresh sample
so this completes the specification of
our algorithm now let's do some sanity
check suppose we have the growl truth
what would happen let's first check the
decoding so if you plug in the
pseudo-inverse just cancels out the
crowd should and then you get X star
because it is non-negative so relew
doesn't do anything so you get a grouch
whose x star 0 yeah yeah yeah haha so
you can think about how Phi has a small
constant returns your own one so yeah so
I didn't specify oh yeah oh sorry yeah
it's dead okay yeah
okay now let's check the update so in
this case if you plug this in and also
plug the to decoding let me get that is
proportion to a star so you are moving
along the right direction but there's
some scaling here so we need to have
different step sizes to take into
account the scale issue but anyway the
update Direction is just the groucho
just pointing to the Grouch's so this
seems reasonable yes but it turns out
that because we only assume linear
independence of the columns of a so if
the matrix a is far away from the
Grouch's um basically we we cannot say
anything about everything so we're
things can happen we have some example
showing that you can get very weird
things so for simplicity sorry we just
assume that the initialization is close
to look route roots up to a constant
arrow what do I mean by arrows here
basically means then the columns of a is
the linear combination of the columns in
a star and in particular is a times a
star times a large diagonal mages plus a
small of tango mages so to pass what
this means let's look at a column of a
then if you expand this out basically
means it's a combination of the
corresponding grouchos column we want a
I star and some other some components
from other columns in a star so the
assumption basically means that you have
a large fraction along the or the one
that you want and all the others are
just
Austin just takes up a small constant
friction so we can relax this a little
bit but we cannot make it a larger than
a half so we gonna haves it's a not even
like identifiable with things and we're
things happen so so now under these
three assumptions we can have this clean
our theorem saying that after log of 1
over epsilon iterations you pasted you
get the arrow or to be epsilon so here
we still maintain this to be 1 minus L
but if you know that the columns of the
grout truth has not has column norm one
so you can then you can just do
normalization and and then after
normalization you can get this to be one
minus order epsilon so basically it's
just means then you can get our epsilon
arrow afternoon like logarithm
iterations
Oh
better why so you look at the that the
columns of your resume that have the
component and you keep those and then
you get codex now in this particular
simple general the model yes but it
turns out that the same intuition can be
generalized to the case that you might
you might not even be able to recover
the support of X star yeah for the for
the spa's case with zero and one is easy
to recover the support and things like
that but the integer here that i'm going
to describe applies to more general
setting then you may not be able to
recover the support even sure i'm asking
is that the non sparse case or which
piece yeah non-sports case Yeah Yeah
right
okay so how do we analyze so it turns
out that this expression is the
beginning of how analysis so we just try
to show the method can maintain large
Sigma and at the same time just may be
the arrow matches e or decrease so we
need to have some measure or some
measurement to measure the size of this
arrow mages so we divide this potential
function which is basically take theta
norm of the positive power of E Taylor
norm of the neck deep on and do a raid
accommodation it seems a very real
potential function but anyway if we can
show these two things we can prove the
theorem right oh so now let's focus on
this arrow mages and this potential
function to see why we want this beer
thing here why not just use the norm of
the arrow mages as a whole it turns out
that it's basically because the rail
yunnan uniforms are non-linear function
choose the positive power and the
negative power in different ways you can
remove the negative noise but you cannot
remove the positive noise so you need to
achieve the two parts in two different
ways okay to be more specific now let's
first look at arm the decoding let's
simplify things by assuming that the
Sigma majors is just the identity
because we always keep it too close to
one so so let's just say its identity
although this assumption let's see how
the arrow matches is change by the
update rule let's first look at the
decoding if we plug the expression of a
into the decoding room then basically is
just this expression you take the
inverse of
identity + gr images and times X star so
if we do a Taylor expansion so it looks
like this so we also need a handle the
high order them is not so easy to handle
but the intuition is that it consists
the crowd truth that we want and also
some arrow related to our this arrow
mages right so let's say some noise
related to this arrow mages okay so you
can imagine that the nonlinear function
Tyrell you here is just to remove this
noise okay now let's look at the entries
of this x star minus e times x star so
it looks like this the green bars stands
for say the nonzero entries in the
groucho x star and the yellow ones are
just noise introduced by this second
term so it basically looks like
something like this it turns out there
although the total amount of noise is
large they are spread out so you can
imagine if you set this off are properly
you can remove a large fraction of the
noise while maintaining a large fraction
of this crowd should take one so you get
a much cleaner version after doing this
our value function so this is the
basically the weibull uni red okay if
alpha 0 0 you will not remove the
positive yes so we also can be 0 yeah it
come is 0 positive nice as that for
um if you have positive yeah it has
positive noise right so sometimes you
have possibly noise that can for example
you you have a positive noise into this
so basically relew cannot like have a
good effect on that that's why um lado
munir delicate potential function is
there some relation between alpha and s
so effects if you knew the X text was
going to be very sparse then maybe you
want to write so um in this in this
simplifying so in a more general setting
alpha has depends on quite a few things
that there is this one in this simplify
setting um yeah I think it um I didn't
did a calculation but yeah it also
depends on the sparsity but yeah I think
it depends on
so if you don't know this varsity then
you right so basically this is something
that we we need to let see more about
basically because our guarantee is
something like this is a set of
parameters alpha and step size 801 802
so say you can get this thing but yeah
oh okay yeah I'm getting close so after
doing the decoding you can plug in into
this and do a bunch of calculation that
is not so interesting but at the end of
the day the update or on the air images
looks like this so this is the original
arrow mages I mean in the previous
iteration and after one update you just
modify by moving along this update
direction and this update direction oh
yeah the green stands for the positive
entries in air images and the yellow one
stands for the negative of course I just
may made them into two parts but they
can be like scattering around just for
simplicity and it turns out that the
update direction so this tell damages
here has a very specific form you first
take the original arrow meeches e
transpose it and then you will scale
down the positive entries by small
constant Y basically is because as I
said if you have a positive and you hear
its effect on the decoding let's say on
the decoding is contributing a negative
noise so you can imagine that if kind of
light can be most of the time it can be
like threshold by this non this random
function so right this is your bed for
the I
for the other part the negative entries
you don't have this nice property but it
turns out that this more constant on
this positive part are sufficient so
basically if you set at a 1 adder to
properly you can make sure that the
Sigma images stays close to one and you
can also also make sure that is negative
this positive power will not be blow up
too much by this negative parts and on
the other hand the negative parts would
be decrease because of this small
constant so then by a weighted
combination you can show that this
actually decrease but if you just use
the the norm of the arrow mean chess
[ __ ] and do not use the weighted
combination it can actually sometimes
increase a little bit but if you
consider this way the combination and
you can show that it always decrease so
then we get out of this oh ok so this
kind of analysis can also be applied to
some other more general setting for
example we have noise to each column or
why this is basically because you can
handle this kind of noise in the same
way as before you can imagine that
you're just adding an additional noise
job here and then you can argue using
the previous intuition so it turns out
that you can tolerate large adversary
noise and if the noise is zero mean the
noise can be a square root K larger than
the l1 norm of the of the signal I'll be
yeah so so this is very strong the noise
in your fame by the relo so it's not i
od oh yeah no no assumption I mean in
this setting is normal something
yeah if you have zero mean then you can
is basically because this and that the
couple and a coupling of the two parts
you can use this our analysis to show
that you actually you don't need much
assumption but the key assumption is
then the noise should be spread out
across different entries um ein so I
should say that it's not totally
adversary but its adversary on each
entry so basically you have an upper
bound on each energy of this noise
vector but it can be any distribution
and wise yeah so it can also be used in
some other distribution of the X star we
only need need to recertify satisfy some
moment condition about the sector first
moment and second moment so is quite
general but we still need the
coordinates to be independent of each
other why because when when when we from
this step is decoding to showing this
basically you need the net independence
of the coordinate so that you get a lot
of cancellation here yeah that's the
high-level intuition
so there's summarized basically we have
the good analysis of this problem under
the assumption or that is fair in mind
but we still need a warm star and then
we discovered a very strong too noisy
effect of the rail you so it can make
use of the non- non-negativity
constraints in this particular problem
yeah okay yeah this one quick question
while the next speaker is setting up
do you need to know about each other
meds oh yeah oh yeah indie you can do
binary search you can do binary search
right but in dr a grizzle need to know
the otha in advance so you can do some
estimation but yeah we need